this meeting it's a pleasure to
introduce krito knocking out from ucsd
who will be talking about
his overfitting has actually been done
so thank you
so this is not going to be an actual
talk it's going to be sort of a progress
report on a project that's in progress
so i'll discuss some motivations show
some plots and post some open questions
that i think we have something to talk
about
all right um
this is going to be going to work with a
number of people so neil in the mirror
here too
with
um
okay so first here's a teaser
we've all seen this experiment
right let me walk through this quickly
so the experiment here is
let's take uh let's train uh some
networks on c5 so d naught
is
the original c5 distribution
and what we're going to do is train on
dp where dp is a noisy version of c5
where with probability t we have a
uniformly random label okay
now as we very p we're going to do the
following let's we'll train a network to
interpolation
on samples from the noisy distribution
and then evaluate test error on the
clean distribution
do not
and we've seen
this plot
here so what happens is as we very label
corruption
e
look at how networks perform on clean
labels and we see the following thing
where
increasing amount of label noise in the
train set shows up as
a test time
and this plot is usually
shown as evidence of some kind of benign
overfitting like that these are cases
where
interpolating noise on the train set
does not somehow hurt you too much
uh but it does hurt you right note that
uh
that you you are incurring more tests
when you train on noisy distributions
and and in particular for higher noise
rates you'll follow some base optimal so
the base optimal classifier in the
setting would would just be this flat
line down here for any for any noise
level besides 100 noise as long as you
have some signal the base optimal
classifier will will recover that signal
so the question here is
in this in for this finite sample
setting we're seeing that noise does
actually hurt
and and what happens yeah yeah
yeah yeah please please like whenever
you say it's a horizontal line
0.1
oh yeah yeah you're saying this this
distribution itself might be noisy as i
was saying sure yeah yeah so
are you my body movement
yeah the point that you see there at 0.1
might not be
oh sorry i'm basically like if this was
if this was if there was no base risk
here then then this would just be flat
at zero as days after month i'll i'll
show much simpler settings so we can
actually understand what the base
optimal classifier is this is sort of
motivation
um but the question really is okay this
is one this is a finite end what happens
what would happen to this plot as you
increase them
will will these lines get closer and
closer to base optimal or will there
always be some
lower bound of the effect of noise it
will noise always
yeah yeah and the question is like do
these points will they at least converge
to to what we know is the episode right
but but you can feel this we have
simpler settings we can understand it
better
um so by the way notice that
your better and better networks seem to
be getting closer and closer to this to
this line here
i mean in fact that does seem to be
happening with other papers which among
other things
shows that for very good networks you
have this effect the training on two
percent noisy inputs
on the train side will produce a
classifier with roughly 80 percent noisy
outputs and this is so even for
structured forms of labor noise and it
seems to be true uh even for varying the
size varying and this is sort of
independent of
so for any larger n as long as you
interpolate you see that in fact
um this paper studies generalizations of
this phenomenon they won't discuss that
here but
in this project we're going to study
the consistency implications of this
statement
and try to understand how to simplify
this setting as much as possible to try
to understand what's going on
okay yeah and also like yeah please
enter that way there's no real time
okay so let me define what i mean by
consistency and then we'll we'll discuss
the experiments so
uh we have some distribution d on inputs
x labels y
we have some models that map inputs to
labels
and we have some notion of a loss
function on models so
this could be uh in the regression
setting this will be the mean squared
earth classification setting to zero one
loss
and given the loss in the distribution
we got this notion of the optimal not
loss
which is just the best the best loss
that's achievable for the distribution
okay
now what is a learning method a learning
a learning algorithm
is a sequence
of algorithms indexed by sample size
and each algorithm takes in n samples
and splits out a model
so allowing learning algorithms to be
non-uniform and that they do different
things for different sizes of samples
but you often want like in a
non-parametric case you would change a
bandwidth according to the sample size
and things like that
just generically
okay so with this setup what is
consistency
we say a learning method
is consistent for a given distribution
with respect to a given loss
if in the limit
of in the asymptotic limit of samples
the learning method converges to the
optimal the optimal law
right so this is this is consistency
note in particular we're not changing
the problem right like the dimension of
the problem is staying the same the only
thing that's changing is the number of
samples
there's consistency for a fixed so
this particular we say it's consistent
if asymptotically the algorithms
converge to the optimal loss okay good
and now the question we ask is are
modern
learning methods consistent or modern
interpolating learning methods
consistent so they ask this question
have to define what what i mean by a
modern learning method
roughly we want to be considering a
sequence
of algorithms that correspond to
training networks of increasing size
that you want to grow the size of the
network with the size of the data
there are two natural ways to do this
roughly
is the over parameterized limit
where you do this while keeping the
network size always bigger than the data
size and training to interpolation
and then there's the under pyramid size
limit where you you go the size of the
network but always slower than the size
of the data and this is sort of the
classical the classical limit
and i claim that these two limits
have different behavior particularly
the underpayment size limit is often
consistent like
it's easy to formulate versions of state
to formulate the statement in ways that
you can show it to be consistent sort of
for classical reasons so if the data is
large enough uh as long as your model
family is growing in exclusivity you
will you will you will reach consistency
and there are others of this in various
settings
uh masters targarsky joyly and justin
have this early start networks are
consistent
paper recently which proves some version
of this
but this should be the classical limit
the overpayment size limit is what we
want to study now which is
uh here and i claim that
there's evidence that this is
inconsistent in sort of almost all
reasonable settings
um clearly not all of them right because
we know the
it's possible to interpolate and be
consistent but somehow the wide variety
like in practice if you actually train
networks they see me consistent now okay
let me show a very simple yeah
in sort of a reasonable way
and would then sort of prove it like
like massachusetts paper to some version
of this
okay
yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah so then
dependent limit is really meant to
capture this thing when you don't
overfit like when the trainer is close
to your test era
so so you can you can also you can
instantiate this limit as saying like
you can also do the one epoch training
like we just trained for one epoch uh
then you should also get consistency
like yeah basically the independent
number should be cases when the train
error is close to the tester you have
normal
generalization balance and optimizing on
the train set is
exactly what you want
there are various ways to formalize
something like that
yeah yeah
yeah so
so uh
yeah this this could be trickier and
even not known for deeper networks
um if you if you allow yourself infinite
optimization time
then then you can make this i mean yeah
but i think i think even i think
i think like morally this is true and
like the question is
how far can we prove that it's true
it's a different question
i think a more precise way to say is to
say that if you can optimize it if you
can find the problem
yeah that's definitely true
yeah
yeah
but i wanna study this one now which
will be checked the ministry setting for
his ecosystem
um so here's so like let's start to
simplify the setting as much as possible
to understand the behavior so it's a
very simple distribution uh
the practice of different x and y x is
some normal gaussian in some dimension
on the dimensions y is independent of x
and that's the plus minus one bit
with some bias
can even be unbiased
now consider
solving the regression problem in the
setting so the optimal regression
function is just a constant function
it's the bias of the bit
for example devices the optimal function
is just the actual function
now
what happens if we try to solve this
regression problem we keep learning
right we take some neural network and we
train it to interpolation
on samples from the distribution
do we learn as a function do we learn
the constant function
uh and if you do this experiment
there's a lot of design choices here
right like you have to choose what kind
of video or or
all the designers but i claim like uh if
you try to do it for almost all
reasonable type of parameters
you will not see consistency so here uh
as you increase the size of the samples
and look at
the excess the excess width
the accessories did not convert to zero
as much samples
consider this setting are you solving
regression in a very simple case
x is a normal vector in 100 dimensions
y
is independent of x
and some unknown by a biased bit and you
want to solve the regression problem in
this case the optimal function is
constant
the question is if you train an mlt
to interpolation do you learn the
constant function
and i claim
that
if you if you actually try this so any
actual instantiation as an mlp
that you train to interpolation you will
not learn the constant function you will
not even convert to the current yeah
yeah this also holds for like one one
layer
so what is the these ones these 100 here
this also both of these like uh you know
with 10 10 1000. yeah it doesn't matter
but those details don't matter so you
know we've changed the way we change the
depth we change the initialization scale
as long as you interpolate i claim
you're not going to get this consistency
if anyone breaks this if anyone can
break this
like show me some natural painting that
that will that will be consistent will
be very you know we haven't found it
is it what is it
it's not important
this will be full for the next slide
in fact it's the same thing yeah i'll
show you i'll show you actually we have
the next slide yeah so here we go so
hold that right so it's not a problem
right if you stop after one epoch then
you're going to be consistent easily
this is like a 1d5 version of this
you don't if you don't interplay it's
very easy you can learn the control
function it should be obvious
um
so
what i'm saying is
do you because i want to tell you
consistency i want to study oh is this
method consistent as i said
the question is yeah we want to we don't
know the answer product behavior of this
line
any other questions
yeah so uh let's look it's easy to
understand the classification setting so
strain on the exact same thing exact
same distribution
but now you care about the
classification loss
do the exact same thing just measure the
class the measure the classification
zero one error
so now the optimal function you know you
have p p bias
on the y is the optional function is
just the one function
right
the classification loss
then an mlp same thing
look at how as you vary the the the p as
you vary the train distribution
i would be how do you vary the virus at
the input how does the bias at the
output change
right you also understanding so this is
this is changing the training
distribution the bias the bias of y
and this is looking at the bias f
so the optimal thing here the base
optimal thing is the step function that
any any bi is less than half the optimal
function zero anybody's more than half
the outcome function is one
what's the training
this experiment was msc but this works
for consent to b2 my previous paper on
distribution
no no so there's two questions right
like um
okay so you have to fix that you have to
fix a you have to fix the training
method
you can change with whatever loss you
want then you
is
is
i think you have to be
it's fine but then you shouldn't say
ideally what you should get is sine
theoretically i mean or sine of p minus
1
ideally
so yeah so the law of values would be p
but how do you obtain a classifier out
of the function that you get you you
threshold it
and then you'll get you then you'll get
plus then you have plus or minus one
right like when you take the arg max
when you turn it over
and that's what that's what we're
measuring
so we we turn it into regression then we
threshold the function and use it as a
classifier which is what we do
right
so what are you showing here actually
so it's
so if we say if it's really
sign
yes yes but that's that's yeah i mean
this is implicitly like what you do when
you use regression for classification
right
you take the like max of the existence
yeah so this is like this
to your previous question which is as
you change the bias of the input like
this is telling you about the structure
of the function like what function do
you actually get
and the point is that you know you're
getting something that is very close to
this line that the that the noise level
at the outpost
is close to the noise level of the
inputs
this statement is in general like
generalized in my previous paper on
distributional generalization
but uh the point for our for our
experiments is that this behavior does
not change as you scale up the samples
so in particular as you scale up the
samples here from
the 128 to 20k if you're not getting
closer to base optimal
you're deflating that
inconsistent
okay let me speed up so yeah there's an
intuition so yeah let me just skip this
um
yeah okay so here's the status of this
project and open questions that are
they're allowed to address
um we have some sort of negative
observations in the process the negative
the many settings for interplaying
lessons are inconsistent
on the positive side
uh so inc in the regression setting uh
you can write this as bias plus variance
and you can ask if you're inconsistent
or inconsistent because of the bias
because of the variance and there's
empirical evidence that you know neural
networks are asymptotically unbiased
okay so
the the bias is right
but you're inconsistent because the
variance does not go to zero i think the
statement that networks are
asymptotically biased is unbiased is
already interesting and it would be nice
to do that like i think this is sort of
a
statement that if it's true it's
sufficiently strong that we might be
able to move it but i haven't i don't
know how to do it
but i'm biased in the sense that in the
classical sense of like
is it point wise unbiased
as a regressor
over the training procedure so this is
like in the normal in the biased sense
of like this in statistical life
training data in any randomness in the
training procedure itself
yeah you would in particular would have
this exact relation between
the input bias and the bias
so was the asymptotic unbiasedness claim
clear
yeah so like point-wise you're getting
the bias you're just not getting
vanishing variance
yeah so so there's a negative that's the
positive
the the what the interesting thing is we
have a lot of theoretical settings where
overfitting is behind like where we know
interpolators can be consistent under
some assumptions
on the other hand we have a lot of
experiments where that seem also natural
but interpolating is not does not appear
consistent so the question is what is
the gap can we can we can understand
which of these assumptions break down
and and can this guide us towards maybe
more realistic assumptions that they
capture these settings
why is overfitting benign in silly but
nothing in fact this is the question
um
and then another thing is like coming
through this asymptotic unbiasedness
um here's a very clean theory of the
question that i think can make
logarithms but maybe i think we're going
to assume that we have the tools to
answer this question
uh consider this the same setting x is x
is gaussian
y is also gaussian independent of x
you use an rbs kernel you interpolate
with an rbf kernel or with a laplace
cover
right
now for what choices are banned with is
the lbf kernel consistent
so if we consider the interpolating
method as training an rbf kernel to
infiltration
but it was a particular bandwidth choice
can we understand for which choice are
bandwidth the ibf kernel is consistent
or inconsistent and is there any choice
that makes it consistent so extremely
simple setting right like there's no
there's no label structure everything is
awesome i feel like we should be able to
understand it maybe someone
uh has done it
like for some choices it isn't
i think we haven't found a setting that
is consistent yet although it's
maybe murky like we haven't completely
figured this out yet there are some that
look like they're consistent as the
bandwidth is increasing there's certain
bandwidth that
seems to show some inconsistency it
needs to be explored yeah it's not clear
even that i don't know i haven't
actually seen like
yeah but you can't scale the problem
size you you don't want to scale the
problem the dimensions with the examples
you want to like i haven't seen any
results even first positive results yet
the number of kernels is
yeah there's only one thing that changes
the size
maybe there's another one
very much over time so thank you and uh
send me an email if you solve any
problems
[Music]
oh
so
um
is